[Música]
colombia y venezuela se acerca
nuevamente después de casi cuatro años
sin relaciones diplomáticas desde antes
de su posesión el presidente gustavo
petro informó su intención por
restablecer los lazos diplomáticos y en
todo sentido y abrir oficialmente los
pasos fronterizos ayer jueves ambos
países anunciaron los nombres de quienes
serían sus nuevos embajadores y
recientemente venezuela señaló que
restablecería de inmediato sus
relaciones militares con colombia y
expectativa además en la frontera ante
la reapertura de la misma importante
para la reactivación de la economía pues
todo esto lo vamos a analizar con
daniela monroy a la investigadora
adscrita del observatorio de venezuela
en colombia de la universidad de rosario
además cuenta con experiencia y análisis
de la relación bilateral entre colombia
venezuela movilidad humana y temas de
frontera colombo venezolana daniela muy
buena mañana de viernes gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
hola raúl - días muchas gracias a ti por
tenerme acá daniela hablemos digamos
para entrar en contexto de las
implicaciones que tiene reanudar todo
este tipo de relaciones entre colombia y
venezuela pausadas definitivamente desde
el año 2019 principios de 2019 bueno
primero las comerciales realmente
economía horita tiene la necesidad
imperiosa abrir la frontera hay mucha
gente esperando la apertura de hecho las
expectativas estaban bastante altas en
el sentido de que la gente esperaba que
al día siguiente la posición
presidencial la frontera se hiciera o se
hiciera efectiva la apertura eso no ha
ocurrido realmente vemos que el proceso
realmente tiene que ser gradual tiene
que ver primero una activación real de
las embajadas como bien lo decías
ahorita apenas han designado en los 22
embajadores tanto en colombia como en
venezuela habrá que esperar que ese
proceso realmente avance y que los
diálogos sean impulsados hacia una
verdadera apertura comercial ahorita y
paso peatonal el paso peatonal pues está
un poco restringido pero esta está
activo lo que falta es un paso vehicular
y un paso realmente comercial que lleve
a activar toda la zona fronteriza en
este momento pues cúcuta tiene un
desempleo bastante alto ese desempleo y
esa reactivación económica que todavía
no ha ocurrido en cúcuta es necesaria y
tiene que pasar por la reapertura
fronteriza e igualmente en venezuela o
una pequeña oportunidad económica la
leve recuperación económica de venezuela
pues eso también es una oportunidad para
la apertura fronteriza daniela de acción
en materia de comercio pero
políticamente hablando a que nos
enfrentamos a muchas cosas y muchas
dificultades creo que el nombramiento de
los embajadores fue necesario y se se
hace efectivo ahorita porque el diálogo
es es inminente y tiene que haber una
actitud bastante hábil de parte del
embajador viene de parte también del
canciller álvaro leyva aquí en colombia
a pesar de que el cambio de gobierno
hacia pe de educación petro es positivo
en cierto sentido en restablecer la
relación bilateral todavía quedan muchas
cosas pendientes creo que quedan
tensiones todavía todavía están digamos
los los bloqueos simbólicos de la
frontera todo lo que ocurrió con los
contenedores todavía hay muchos rezagos
de eso y a pesar de que pedro pues se ha
mostrado abierto también él tiene que
ser bastante hábil porque en este tema
con venezuela se juega su favorabilidad
por supuesto tiene que ser bastante
hábil en ese sentido porque la gente
aquí en colombia todavía está muy
reticente para todo lo que tiene que ver
con mando y por supuesto que en la
frontera pues tienen que ver temas que
son muy importantes para colombia cómo
es la negociación con lln que pues esta
semana también se supo de la delegación
que fue enviada hacia cuba para cumplir
ese cometido temas ambientales que están
bastante
presentes en la agenda de petro sobre
todo en temas internacionales temas de
paz obviamente el canciller álvaro leyva
pues ha dicho petro que es un caso ayer
para la paz y de hecho pues el tema de
cultivos ilícitos narcotráfico
paramilitarismo guerrillas todo eso es
también escuela presente entonces
realmente es muy difícil gobernar
colombia sin gobernar la frontera claro
mucho trabajo por hacer' daniela te
referías cuando cuando comentabas los
contenedores al episodio que vimos
precisamente cuando fue la ruptura de
gramos definitiva de estas relaciones
bilaterales entre colombia y venezuela
principio 2019 cuando él pues el que se
denominaba presidente interino venezuela
juan guaidó quiso entrar esta ayuda
humanitaria cuando se hizo todo este
concierto por la paz en cúcuta para la
ayuda a venezuela como que digamos la
figura de one bites o de juan guaidó que
va a ser gustado petro en relación a
este líder opositor imagino qué no sé si
nada porque pues ya está digamos
reconociendo al gobierno de nicolás
maduro con esta reapertura de la
frontera con esta relación que van a
tener estos dos países como antes
digamos de 2019 y también digamos la
posición de eeuu un gran aliado de
colombia cómo ve este acercamiento de
colombia y venezuela aunque recordemos
también que pues eeuu se está volcando
también digamos a venezuela por el tema
del petróleo no sí yo creo que tanto de
parte de colombia como en parte de eeuu
evidencia como una actitud más
pragmática hacia a venezuela a eeuu por
supuesto le preocupa el tema del
petróleo el tema más económico y
cualquier cosa revisar las sanciones
todo lo que está pasando en ese sentido
el presidente va a ir en pues ha sido
muy preciso en revisar esos temas y en
lo que compete a colombia pues pero
también antes de hablar de
reconocimiento de waldo de la oposición
de venezolana aquí en colombia pues ha
preocupado más por hablar del tema
fronterizo de revisar temas de paz con
venezuela él de hecho desde la campaña
había sido muy exacto en que iba a
revisar la reapertura fronteriza y la
relación con venezuela con cuál que
fuera el gobierno que allí estuviera
pero por supuesto que los migrantes aquí
en colombia muchos de ellos pues están
en contra de maduro y por supuesto que
les daría un parte de tranquilidad saber
qué es lo que va a pasar con respecto a
la oposición no porque hay temas también
importantes con respecto a why do y es
que también la embajada de white topes
había adelantado algunas acciones aquí
en colombia para favorecer a los
migrantes y otros temas como por ejemplo
el tema monómeros que tampoco es fácil y
también está atravesado por la oposición
daniela eso le quería preguntar porque
también digamos que hay personas altos
representantes de la oposición política
en venezuela aquí en colombia qué va a
pasar con estas personas no tendrían
como algún tipo de miedo digamos y temor
por alguna posible evolución a venezuela
un proceso de extradición con ellos cuál
es su proceso legal cuál es su estatus
legal mejor dicho aquí en colombia de
estos opositores que se encuentran en
este territorio no pues había ese miedo
desde la campaña desde que se empezó
avisorar que tal vez pedro podría ser el
presidente y aquí colombia se especulaba
mucho sobre cómo iba a actuar petro con
respecto a las personas que querían ser
refugiados o asilados
evidentemente colombia tiene pendiente
un montón de solicitudes de asilo no sé
si pero dentro de su cancillería podría
gestionarlas todas pero al menos creo
que sí es importante dar un parte de
tranquilidad con respecto a julio borges
con respecto a muchos representantes de
la oposición que están aquí localizados
en colombia pero por supuesto eso
también puede llevar a tensiones con
nicolás maduras y que va a ser
importante ver como petro juega o el
canciller también juega como en ambos en
ambas partes acomodaron parte de
tranquilidad de los migrantes a colo en
colombia con respecto a qué va a pasar
con los líderes de la oposición y por
otro lado también mantener las cosas muy
tranquilas con maduro creo que por eso
que el papel del canciller o álvaro
leyva como negociador pues también va a
ser fundamental ahí cómo jugar a ambas
partes pero con mucha tranquilidad y lo
ha hecho a nivel la digamos que hasta
ahora el gobierno y también el
presidente gustavo petro ya se ha visto
como muy cauteloso no a la hora de
hablar de venezuela no lo nombró en su
discurso de toma de posición el pasado 7
de agosto ningún tipo de relación con
venezuela ni el para la apertura del
paso fronterizo ni absolutamente nada
también ha sido muy cauto digamos en la
relación una posible
llamada
amistad entre comillas que pueda tener
con nicolás maduro está jugando eso no
también a hacer cauteloso ya voy a
buscar a tratar de buscar lo mejor para
estas dos naciones que pues ya se lo
merece no es jazz ahora sí por supuesto
de hecho en la campaña el no haya dicho
mucho sobre venezuela hasta que estuvo
en cúcuta donde prometió la re apertura
fronteriza y hasta unos poquitos días
antes de la elección y posterior a la
elección fue que realmente habló y dijo
de frente petro hable con maduro esa fe
como la declaración más importante con
relación al tema pero igualmente no se
puede dejar de lado que el tema
migratorio el tema monómero es el tema
oposición el tema venezuela en general
estuvo presente en las negociaciones del
empalme presidencial entonces aunque
petro de pronto sea muy cauto y muy
precavido a la hora de hablar de
venezuela en público no hay que dejar
del lado que es un tema que el gobierno
tiene presente que expertos por supuesto
que una frontera de 2.219 kilómetros y
un vecino como venezuela pues es una
relación que no se puede dejar de lado
entonces creo que es es importante tener
en cuenta ese tema ha estado presente
ahí y que igualmente va a ser un tema
fundamental para el canciller y vuelvo
al tema al que mencionaba anteriormente
el tema de la negociación con lln
tampoco se puede dejar de lado flor en
la negociación con venezuela